.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Cheese!
Wir beide
wollen Zahnärztinnen werden.
Dieser Beruf gefällt uns.
Diese Chance,
die mir angeboten wird,
sollte ich nutzen -
und ich werde sie nutzen.
Ich kann Neues lernen
und mein Wissen vertiefen.
Und das bringt viel
bei der Aufnahmeprüfung.
Sie alle wollen eine gute Ausbildung.
Acht Monate lang begleiten wir sie
auf ihrem Weg zur Gymiprüfung.
So.
Herzlich willkommen
im Gymnasium Unterstrass
zum Aufnahmeprozedere von ChagALL 9.
Es ist das neunte Jahr,
dass wir dieses Programm führen.
Victoria?
- Ja.
An Schweizer Gymnasien
stammen weniger als 10 % der Schüler
aus fremdsprachigen Familien.
Das Schulhaus Unterstrass in Zürich
hat vor zehn Jahren
das Projekt "Chancengerechtigkeit
durch Arbeit an der Lernlaufbahn" -
kurz: ChagALL - lanciert.
Carina?
- Ja.
Es geht für uns
ein Stück weit um Gerechtigkeit.
Es gibt in diesem Land
junge Menschen,
die das Potenzial und den Arbeits-
willen haben, einsatzfreudig sind.
Mit ein bisschen mehr Unterstützung
können sie schulischen Erfolg haben,
eine gute Lehre,
eine Berufsmittelschule machen.
Begabte Jugendliche von Migranten-
familien mit niedrigen Einkommen
werden auf die Prüfung
für die Mittelschulen vorbereitet.
Man weiss aus der Forschung,
dass es für ein Kind
mit Migrationshintergrund,
fremdsprachig, enorm schwierig ist,
in eine höhere Klasse
eingestuft zu werden -
gleiche Leistung, 4,5.
Wenn ich Lea heisse,
mein Vater Jurist
und meine Mutter Primarlehrerin ist,
beide aus der Schweiz,
dann werde ich natürlich
in die Sekundarstufe A eingestuft.
Aber ein Schüler aus dem Kosovo,
dessen Eltern in Hilfsberufen tätig
und der deutschen Sprache
nicht mächtig sind,
hat diese Chance nicht.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Ich habe mit unserem Direktor
über meine Zukunft
am Gymnasium Unterstrass gesprochen.
Plötzlich übergab er mir eine Mappe,
auf der "ChagALL" stand.
Ich war damals die einzige Person
mit Migrationshintergrund,
sowohl im Lehrer- als auch im
Schülerkorpus der ganzen Schule.
Er meinte, ich sei ideal dafür,
soll es mir mal anschauen,
man brauche eine operative Leitung.
Die Eltern von Stefan Marcec,
beide Zahnärzte,
kamen vor rund 50 Jahren
aus Slowenien in die Schweiz.
Ich hatte einfach das Glück,
dass ich aus einem Elternhaus kam,
das mir eine Bildungskarriere
ermöglichen konnte.
Ich wurde in den späten 70er- und
den 80er-Jahren damit konfrontiert,
was es heisst,
Ausländer in der Schweiz zu sein,
was heisst, einfach anders zu sein,
was es heisst,
in einer Form
nicht wirklich dazuzugehören.
So, herzlich willkommen.
Die erste Hürde habt ihr schon
genommen, ihr sitzt jetzt da.
Wir freuen uns,
dass sich dieses Jahr
so viele Leute
für ChagALL angemeldet haben.
In diesem Jahr wurden
rund 40 Schülerinnen und Schüler
von ihren Lehrern empfohlen.
Die Bereitschaft, Freizeit zu opfern,
Lernwille und Motivation
gehören
zu den wichtigsten Aufnahmekriterien.
Anders als in den
meisten anderen Kantonen
darf im Kanton Zürich
nur ans Gymnasium,
wer die Aufnahmeprüfung schafft.
Matthias ist seit drei Jahren
in der Schweiz.
Sein Vater ist Schweizer und lebt
in Bolivien, seine Mutter Ungarin.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Sicher? Bist du nervös?
- Ja.
Kommen wir zu den Sprachen.
Du sprichst mit uns jetzt
Hochdeutsch.
Du kannst aber auch
ein wenig Schweizerdeutsch. - Ja.
Dann sprichst du Spanisch?
- Ja.
Ungarisch? - Ja.
- Englisch? - Ja.
Was noch?
- Ein bisschen Französisch.
Ein bisschen Französisch.
Was möchtest du später mal machen?
Was stellst du dir so vor?
Das weiss ich noch nicht ganz genau.
Falls es mit dem Gymi nicht klappt,
werde ich Informatiker lernen
und dann im Bereich Informatik
etwas machen.
Sonst bin ich noch etwas unsicher.
Gut. Dann bitten wir dich,
mal draussen zu warten.
(Frau) Also ich würde ihm
diese Chance gewähren.
Er muss natürlich auch ...
Auch wegen des Wechsels ...
Er kam von Ungarn hierher.
Davor noch von Bolivien nach Ungarn,
dann von Ungarn hierher.
Zwei Jahre in der Schweiz -
das ist eigentlich nichts.
Ich finde,
er hat das sehr gut gemacht.
Mohamed wurde in der Schweiz geboren,
seine Eltern kommen aus Somalia.
Du darfst dich hinsetzen
auf den grossen Stuhl.
Mohamed, erzähl uns doch bitte
etwas über dich, deine Familie ...
Ich besuche zurzeit die zweite Sek A
im Schulhaus Riedenhalden,
und ich möchte mal
an der ETH studieren.
Was machen deine Eltern?
Mein Vater
arbeitet als Holzarbeiter.
Holzarbeiter?
- Holzbearbeiter.
Was bearbeitet er denn so?
Urnen.
Meine Mutter ist Hausfrau.
- Mhm.
Du hast auch noch
ein paar Geschwister.
Ja, vier Geschwister.
- Vier Geschwister.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Mohamed kommt aus Somalia.
In seiner Freizeit hält er sich
gerne an der frischen Luft auf
und fährt Velo oder Skateboard.
Er besucht ChagALL, weil er
Ingenieur oder Arzt werden möchte.
* Applaus *
Die 14-jährige Franciska
kommt aus Kroatien.
In ihrer Freizeit
spielt sie gerne Geige.
Französisch ist ihr Lieblingsfach.
Ihre Schwester Viktoria
kommt ebenfalls aus Kroatien.
Am ChagALL-Programm nimmt sie teil,
weil sie Medizin studieren
und Ärztin werden möchte.
Von 40 Bewerberinnen und Bewerbern
wurden schliesslich 26 aufgenommen.
Die Eltern dieser Jugendlichen
stammen aus 15 Ländern.
Während die einen sich
über die Aufnahme
beim ChagALL-Programm freuen,
feiert im Juni 2016 eine Klasse im
Gymnasium Unterstrass die Matura.
Mit dabei ist Roshani,
die vor vier Jahren dank ChagALL
den Sprung ans Gymnasium schaffte.
Am allerersten Schultag mussten wir
unseren Berufswunsch formulieren.
Alle Schüler sagten, sie möchten
irgendeinen Lehrberuf machen -
nur ich sagte:
"Ich möchte Kinderärztin werden."
Seit ich zwei Jahre alt war,
träume ich davon.
Meine Lehrerin
sprach mich dann darauf an,
dass ich am ChagALL-Projekt
teilnehmen könnte.
Da meine Eltern
mir nie helfen konnten
und ich schon in der Volkschule
alles allein machen musste,
habe ich es als nötig erachtet,
dass ich
etwas Unterstützung brauche,
um das Gymnasium zu bestehen.
Erster Schultag.
Zusätzlich zur Sekundarschule müssen
die Schülerinnen und Schüler hier
am Mittwochnachmittag
und am Samstagvormittag
6 Std. für die Gymiprüfung lernen.
Hinzu kommen
noch viele Stunden Hausaufgaben.
So.
Wir beginnen mit dem,
was wir am Samstag machten.
Bitte aufstehen.
Wir machen unser kleines Work-out,
kurz einatmen und ausatmen.
Mohamed, die zweite Übung.
Schwingen?
- Genau.
Achtet darauf, dass ihr eure Finger
nicht an den Stühlen anschlägt.
Und jetzt schwingen wir!
Wir sind kein Altersheim.
Gut. Nächste Übung.
Richtig durchkämmen.
Jetzt stellt euch etwas Solides vor
wie einen Baum oder einen Felsen.
Jeden Trainingsnachmittag eröffnen
wir mit dem sog. ChagALL-Warm-up.
Das ist ein Ablauf
verschiedener Übungen,
die die Schüler
gemeinsam machen und lernen.
Sie erlenen 15 Übungen in einer
Choreografie, in einer Abfolge.
Damit decken wir zwei Punkte ab.
Der erste Punkt ist: Die Schüler
kommen aus verschiedenen Schulen,
waren am Mittwochmorgen noch in der
Schule, in einer anderen Umgebung
und kommen dann zu uns
aufs Gymnasium,
um an dieser Aufnahmeprüfung
zu arbeiten.
Das ist eine Art Fokussierung
der Gruppe aufs gleiche Ziel
durch diese Übungen.
Jede Übung
deckt bestimmte Bereiche ab.
Z.B.: Wenn ich zu lange
am Schreibtisch sitze -
was kann ich machen,
wenn ich verspannt bin,
wenn ich zu aufgeregt
oder zu abgelenkt bin?
Wenn ihr normalerweise
zur Schule geht,
hat die Lehrperson zwei Aufgaben:
Sie unterrichtet und fördert euch,
setzt aber auch Noten.
Versteht ihr?
Sie muss euch fördern und bewerten.
Die Trainerinnen
sind hier in der luxuriösen Lage,
deshalb nennen wir sie auch so,
dass sie euch nicht benoten müssen.
Sie und ich sind hier,
um euch zu helfen.
Also, kommt vorbei, wirklich.
Hoppla, Stufe.
Danke.
- Achtung, Stufe!
Ich habe euch hier
ein Beispiel aufgeschrieben für ...
... ein Pronomen ...
... Adjektiv,
und hier ist das Nomen.
Und jetzt schreibe ich
einen zweiten Satz darunter.
Deutsch ist die Brücke
zum schulischen Erfolg.
Janja Maric
weiss aus eigener Erfahrung,
was ihren Schülerinnen und Schülern
zu Beginn fehlt.
Und jetzt sehen wir,
dass sich das Pronomen verändert:
"ein" wird zu "einen".
Meistens haben sie viel Wissen,
aber es ist vielleicht
noch etwas ungeordnet.
Dann ist es auch schwieriger,
das zur gegebenen Zeit abzurufen.
Lang?
Lang, länger, am langsten.
Du kannst beides nicht.
Egal, machen wir es so.
Viel, mehr am ... Nein.
Doch. Mehr, am ...
... mehrsten?
- Meisten.
Oh, meisten.
- Genau.
ChagALL ist für die Jugendlichen
auch eine gemeinsame Erfahrung.
Sie sind hier
nicht nur Einzelkämpfer.
Wir erleben auch immer wieder,
dass eine Gemeinschaft entsteht.
Viel.
Mehr, am meisten.
- Ja.
Wir haben in den Feedbacks
auch gesehen, dass Schüler sagen,
sie fänden es toll, dass sie
hier nicht ausgelacht würden,
oder es komisch sei,
wenn sie gewisse Fragen stellten,
die darauf zurückgehen, dass Deutsch
nicht ihre Muttersprache sei.
Die, die schwierig waren,
am besten wieder repetieren.
* Sehnsüchtige Klänge *
Manchmal habe ich Schwierigkeiten.
Also, die Schwierigkeiten
liegen nicht im Deutsch,
es ist manchmal einfach schwierig,
einen ganzen Tag durchzuhalten,
wenn man drei verschiedene Sprachen
sprechen muss.
Hinzu kommt,
dass ich zu Hause Ungarisch spreche.
Ich benutze manchmal also
vier oder fünf Sprachen pro Tag.
Ich bin hier zufrieden.
Mir fehlen nur
meine Freunde aus Ungarn.
Und manchmal die Familie.
Denn der grösste Teil meiner Familie
lebt in Ungarn,
der andere Teil in Bolivien.
Ich sehe sie also nicht oft.
Es ist für uns wichtig, dass wir
über die Welt Bescheid wissen,
dass wir auch mitdiskutieren können.
Und deshalb hoffe ich, dass ich
die Aufnahmeprüfung bestehe.
Henriette Stierlin studierte
Literatur und Anthropologie.
Während einer Feldforschung
im bolivianischen Dschungel
lernte sie ihren Mann kennen:
einen Schweizer Tierarzt,
der in Bolivien geboren wurde.
Nach der Trennung
ging sie nach Ungarn,
später kam sie ohne Deutschkenntnisse
in die Schweiz.
Ich denke, das war am schwierigsten.
Ich spreche sehr gut Spanisch
und Englisch, aber kein Deutsch.
Es ist für mich ungewohnt,
nicht gut kommunizieren zu können.
Also habe ich als Erstes
Deutsch gelernt.
Aber es ist nicht immer so einfach,
wie ich habe gedacht ...
... ich gedacht habe -
z.B. die Abfolge der Wörter.
Ich möchte
korrektes Deutsch sprechen.
Es stört mich, dass ich kein
super gutes Deutsch sprechen kann,
auch wenn es
nicht mehr schlecht ist.
Sie arbeitet Teilzeit
in einem Sozialprojekt,
für das sie eigentlich
überqualifiziert ist.
Die dreiköpfige Familie lebt
in Zürich in engen Wohnverhältnissen.
Ich denke,
er ist genetisch Schweizer.
Das sehe ich.
Er mag Ordnung,
alles muss super organisiert sein.
Ohne Kinder könnte ich eine Arbeit
in der Reisebranche finden.
Das wäre für mich
natürlich ein Traum.
Ich mag Reisen,
ich mag meine Arbeit.
Aber wenn man sich
für eine Familie entschieden hat,
dann wächst auch
die Verantwortlichkeit.
Und in dieser Zeit, in der
die Kinder fast Teenager sind,
musste ich mich entscheiden, was
wichtiger ist: ich oder die Kinder?
Und in dieser Zeit
sind das die Kinder.
Sie sind wichtiger als ich -
im Moment.
Nicht immer,
aber im Moment brauchen sie
Stabilität und eine gute Ausbildung.
Ich denke, dass Matthias
in der Schweiz bleiben will.
Das ist klar.
Er ist gerne hier,
findet es hier toll.
Und ich - keine Ahnung.
Im Moment weiss ich es nicht.
* Sie sprechen Ungarisch. *
Dieses Program
braucht sehr, sehr viel Mut.
Oder? Ihr müsst durchziehen können.
Deshalb machen wir
mit euch eine kleine Übung
und danach einen kleinen Test.
Sebi wird euch gleich zeigen,
was wir machen.
Ihr werdet nämlich lernen,
einem scharfen Samuraischwert
auszuweichen.
Mut bedeutet ja nicht,
dass man keine Angst hat,
sondern Mut bedeutet,
dass man trotzdem ruhig bleibt
und nach vorne geht,
auch wenn man Angst hat.
Das vergisst man gerne.
Das Ding ist wirklich scharf.
Diese ungewöhnliche Mutprobe
sei absolut freiwillig,
versicherte uns Marcec.
Ihr habt das toll gemacht.
Ich möchte euch schnell was zeigen.
* Raunen *
Ich hab's doch gesagt.
Wir würden doch nie im Leben
ein scharfes Schwert benutzen.
Das war ein kleiner Test.
Was ihr daraus ziehen sollt, ist:
Geht auf die Gefahr zu,
entspannt euch, atmet.
Schwierige Prüfung - atmen, atmen.
Nicht steif werden!
* Beschwingte Musik *
Ajitha und Viktoria gehen
seit der ersten Sekundarklasse
zusammen in die Schule.
Sie sind beste Freundinnen
und unzertrennlich, wie sie sagen.
Viktoria kam vor acht Jahren
mit ihren Eltern aus der Slowakei
in die Schweiz.
Ajitha wurde als Kind
tamilischer Eltern in Zürich geboren.
Wieso wollt ihr zusammen auftreten?
Wir fühlen uns sicherer, wenn wir
zu zweit sprechen anstatt alleine.
Also mit Ihnen zu sprechen, ja.
Schon von klein auf
wollte ich Zahnärztin werden,
weil ich es spannend fand.
Als ich in die Zahnarztpraxis ging,
haben sie in meinem Mund was gemacht
und ich wusste nie,
was sie genau machten.
Es hat mich interessiert,
was sie dort wohl machen.
Als ich klein war, habe ich
mit Knete Zähne angefertigt
und reingebohrt -
das hat mir Spass gemacht.
Es macht mir auch Spass,
mit kleinen Dingen zu arbeiten.
Mit den Händen, ganz präzise.
Wie ist das zu Hause?
Können dir Vater oder Mutter
bei den Hausaufgaben helfen?
Ich löse die Hausaufgaben
eigentlich alleine,
weil sie nicht alles verstehen,
was ich ihnen zeige.
Dann ist es auch schwierig,
wenn ich ihnen alles erklären muss.
Dann mache ich es lieber alleine
oder frage meine Geschwister.
Quand je me présente,
qu'est-ce que je dis?
De quoi est-ce que je parle?
Je me présente,
qu'est-ce que je nomme?
L'âge.
- L'âge.
Mohamed.
- Je ... seize ans.
C'est bien, c'est bien.
Attention, j'ai!
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass
für viele Schüler das Thema ...
... Integration sehr dominant ist,
auch in diesem Alter.
Sie wollen sich anpassen,
so sein wie die Schweizer Kinder.
Sie müssen schon
eine Leistung erbringen.
Und dann kommt noch die Schule dazu.
Sie sind schon sehr gefordert.
Je suis ...
Die Motivation
ist im Allgemeinen sehr gut.
Die Allermeisten kapieren,
realisieren,
dass sie eine Chance haben,
die sie wahrnehmen können.
Alors, très bientôt,
c'est ton anniversaire.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Einmal im Jahr lädt die Schulleitung
alle ehemaligen Schülerinnen
und Schüler des ChagALL-Programms
zum Brunch ein.
Sie fühlen sich weiterhin
verbunden mit der Schule Unterstrass.
Eine gute Gelegenheit für die Neuen,
sich in einer
freundschaftlichen Atmosphäre
mit den Ehemaligen auszutauschen.
Guten Morgen.
Schön, seid ihr alle da.
Ganz besonders begrüsse ich auch die
Schülerinnen und Schüler aus Basel,
aus der Wirtschaftsmittelschule.
Da gibt es ein vergleichbares
Programm, inspiriert von ChagALL,
das nennt sich ChaBale,
Chance Basel.
Schön, seid ihr da.
Tauscht euch untereinander aus!
Zum heutigen Programm:
Ich weiss, ihr habt alle Hunger.
Ein kleines logistisches Problem ...
Einfach ein Hinweis, bitte.
Zuerst mal maximal
drei Brötchen pro Person.
Denn es wollen alle was haben.
Guten Appetit!
First come, first served.
Das ChagALL-Team bat mich,
ein paar Sätze zu euch zu sagen.
Wenn man aus einem anderen Land
nach Mitteleuropa kommt,
hat man grundsätzlich drei
Möglichkeiten, um vorwärtszukommen.
Die erste ist:
Sportler werden, Profisportler.
Da kam mir Admir in den Sinn,
der mit unseren Kindern
in Oberwinterthur zur Schule ging.
Ich spreche von Admir Mehmedi.
Er spielt jetzt
bei Bayer Leverkusen
und in der Schweizer
Nationalmannschaft.
Er ist
albanisch-mazedonischer Herkunft.
Admir hat offenbar,
so erzählt man es sich bei uns,
in der Schule gesagt,
wenn er etwas nicht verstand:
"Muss ich nicht wissen,
ich werde Profifussballer."
Okay, das ist
tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit,
er hat es ja geschafft.
Die zweite Möglichkeit:
ein eigenes Geschäft eröffnen,
möglichst schnell.
Und es gibt eine dritte Möglichkeit,
und die heisst:
eine gute Berufslehre
und/oder ein Studium.
Aber das bedeutet:
in der Schule gut sein.
Und das ist der Weg,
den ihr gewählt habt.
Bildung.
Aber alle Wege sind anstrengend,
weil ihr ja Nachteile
wettmachen müsst.
Ihr müsst euch
doppelt so fest anstrengen,
weil z.B. die Sprache
die erste Herausforderung ist,
um überhaupt zu verstehen,
was es braucht,
um in diesem Land vorwärtszukommen.
Manchmal
habt ihr es auch doppelt schwer,
weil die Lehrpersonen gar nicht
richtig einschätzen können,
was ihr alles könnt, weil die
Sprache eine Barriere bildet.
Ich wünsche euch alles, alles Gute.
Danke vielmals.
Noch etwas näher!
Kniet hier vorne hin!
Die Schönsten ganz nach vorne!
Jetzt lächeln!
Das Lehrerseminar Unterstrass
wurde Ende des 19. Jh.
nach evangelischen Grundwerten
gegründet.
Es war ein Institut
für Benachteiligte.
Die Schule verfügt heute über ein
Gymnasium und ein Lehrerinstitut.
Die gemeinnützige, private Schule
wird von einem Verein getragen.
Bis anhin ermöglichten
verschiedene Stiftungen gemeinsam
das ChagALL-Programm.
Neu sichert der Kanton Zürich
die Vollfinanzierung
für die nächsten vier Jahre.
Die Erfolgsquote
bei den Schülerinnen und Schülern
betrug bisher
im Durchschnitt rund 70 %.
ChagALL ist erfolgreich,
weil es nicht nur
ein schulisches Förderprogramm ist,
sondern wir
vermitteln auch Lernstrategien,
sprechen
über motivationale Grundhaltungen
und bieten - wenn nötig -
weitere, ergänzende Hilfen.
Wir arbeiten mit kleineren Gruppen.
Unsere Trainerinnen und Trainer
können sich von ihren Ressourcen her
auf jeden Einzelnen
und jede Einzelne einlassen,
Diagnosetests durchführen.
Sie sind genau im Bilde, was jeder
Schüler, jede Schülerin braucht.
Dasselbe gilt auch für mich.
Da die Gruppe kleingehalten ist,
kann ich jeden Schüler,
jede Schülerin kennenlernen.
Ich kann Gespräche führen,
ihre Motivationskrisen erkennen.
Es ist überschaubar.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Mit der Zeit
wird die Doppelbelastung spürbar.
Die Folge: sinkende Motivation.
In dieser Phase führt die Leitung
mehr Gespräche mit den Jugendlichen
und versucht herauszufinden,
wo der Schuh drückt.
Hallo, Matthias.
Du kannst dich setzen.
Wie läuft es in der Schule?
Gut.
Meine Noten werden immer besser.
Erzähl ein bisschen davon!
In Mathe sind die Noten besser,
es gibt keine grossen Schwankungen.
Wie 3 und 5 und so.
Ich habe jetzt eher 4 und 5.
Und jetzt sogar eine 6.
- Wow!
Wo? In Mathe?
- Ja. - Okay.
Wenn ich mir die Unterlagen
anschaue, ist es so,
dass die Feedback-Meldungen
der Trainerinnen nicht gut sind.
Denn, wenn du diese Prüfungen
schaffen möchtest,
dann musst du
noch viel mehr arbeiten.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden mit dir,
was deine Haltung betrifft.
Deine ...
Du bist respektvoll,
freundlich, interessiert.
Aber es muss einfach
noch irgendwas geschehen.
Schau, der Punkt ist ganz einfach.
Das, was du hier
mit ChagALL und Schule erlebst,
wird später an einer Mittelschule
dein Alltag sein.
Die Konzentration auf die Schule
ist das eine,
aber ChagALL hilft dir,
durch dieses Tor zu gehen.
Aber dann wird es so weitergehen.
Zentral für ChagALL
sind die Hausaufgaben.
Du kannst nur profitieren,
wenn du die Hausaufgaben löst.
Versetze dich mal in unsere Lage!
Du bist Trainer und siehst,
dass dieser Schüler,
der noch nicht lange da ist,
zwar freundlich,
interessiert und intelligent ist,
aber er in seiner Schule
nur geringfügig besser wird.
Deshalb investiert er
mehr in die Schule,
hat aber keine Zeit fürs Programm.
Verstehst du?
- Ja.
Was würdest du
mit einem solchen Schüler machen?
Was würdest du ihm sagen?
- Hm.
Konzentrieren
oder es vielleicht lassen.
Mhm.
Die Frage ist jetzt:
Wie geht es weiter?
Ja.
Möchtest du im Program bleiben?
- Okay.
Denn wenn du dich konzentrierst,
kannst du es immer noch packen.
Hallo, Mohamed.
- Grüezi.
Schweizerdeutsch, Hochdeutsch?
- Schweizerdeutsch.
Es ist ein Standortgespräch.
Wie läuft es?
Eigentlich gut, ja.
Erzähl etwas darüber!
Ja ...
- Wie läuft es in der Schule?
Eigentlich besser.
In Deutsch habe ich mich verbessert.
Okay, super.
Ich habe z.B. auch gelernt,
wie man mit Nervosität umgehen kann.
Hast du die Übungen gemacht,
die wir jeweils zu Beginn machen?
Ja.
- Und welche gefällt dir am besten?
Jene mit dem Nackenrollen.
Machst du diese ab und zu?
- Ja, immer wieder.
Auch die Überkreuzübung
hilft gegen Nervosität.
Die funktioniert auch, diese ...
- Ja, diese hier.
Du kannst sie mit mir repetieren.
- Ja.
Zack-zack.
Genau, jetzt musst du schauen ...
Wenn du links ...
Du bist rechts über links,
musst aber links über rechts sein.
So?
- Genau.
Dann drehst du,
lehnst dich zurück und atmest.
Ja.
Das solltest du immer machen,
wenn du nervös wirst.
Das fällt auch nicht gross auf.
- Nein.
Was habt ihr da als x bezeichnet?
Deutsch macht an der Prüfung
40 % aus, ebenso Mathematik.
Aber auch da macht v.a. die Sprache
Schwierigkeiten.
Bei der zweiten Aufgabe
haben wir 2x - 2.
Weil die Zahl um 2 kleiner ist
als das Doppelte der ersten.
Es gibt einen Bereich,
in dem unsere Schüler eher
unterdurchschnittlich abschneiden,
das sind die Textaufgaben.
Es ist klar, dass unsere Schüler
da Probleme haben,
denn es geht um das Verstehen
der deutschen Sprache.
Der Text ist ja
in Deutsch geschrieben.
Da stehen sie häufig an -
nicht
an den mathematischen Konzepten,
sondern am Verständnis
des deutschen Textes.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Ajitha hat eine Zwillingsschwester
und einen Bruder,
der eine Berufslehre macht.
Ihr Vater arbeitet als Koch,
ihre Mutter, gelernte Apothekerin,
als Hilfskraft.
Ajitha teilt das Zimmer mit Anita.
Wie kann ich dich
von Anita unterscheiden?
Hm ...
* Unverständlich *
Was?
Ich habe
ein schmaleres Gesicht als sie.
Bei ihr ist es hier etwas runder,
bei mir schmaler.
Gibt es Momente, in denen du sagst:
"Ich bin hier eine fremde Person."
Oder spürst du das gar nicht?
Hm ...
Manchmal schon,
manchmal in der Schule.
Ich werde zwar nicht gerade
ausgeschlossen, aber ...
Ja ...
Dort fühle ich mich
manchmal als Fremde.
Wie merkst du das?
Ich weiss nicht,
ich empfinde es einfach so.
Und dir kommt kein Beispiel
in den Sinn?
Hm ...
* Unverständlich *
Ja, wenn wir Gruppenarbeiten machen,
gibt es manchmal Dreiergruppen.
Wir sind dort zu viert,
also meine Kollegin und ich
sind in einer Vierergruppe.
Und wenn man zu dritt arbeiten muss,
wissen sie nicht,
wen sie wählen sollen.
Und wenn ich nicht mit ihr
in der Gruppe bin,
fühle ich mich etwas ausgeschlossen.
Wenn man dich fragen würde,
wo deine Heimat ist -
was würdest du sagen?
Dass meine Heimat hier ist,
weil ich hier aufgewachsen bin.
Und ... ja.
Wo hast du mehr Freunde?
Hier oder in Sri Lanka?
In Sri Lanka habe ich
mehr Verwandte, nicht Freunde.
Also habe ich hier mehr Freunde.
Was erzählt ihr von der Schweiz,
wenn ihr in Sri Lanka seid?
* Sie sprechen Tamil. *
Wir sprechen nicht oft über
die Schweiz, wenn wir dort sind.
Wir spielen zusammen
und sprechen über etwas anderes.
Dieses Ressourcentraining,
das wir heute betreiben,
ist ein sehr, sehr gut erforschtes
Selbstmanagement-Training.
Und es ermöglicht euch,
in schwierigen Situationen
an eurem Ziel dranzubleiben.
Mit diesem Ressourcentraining
und diesen Bildern,
die wir kreiert haben,
mit diesen Mottos,
also v.a. mit den Bildern,
die ihr selbst kreiert habt,
kann euer Gefühl etwas anfangen.
Es weiss:
"Da geht es hin. Da wollen wir hin."
Und dann haben wir
daraus ein Motto gemacht.
Das Motto ist sprachlich, verbindet
unser Gehirn mit unserem Herzen,
wenn wir die Gefühle ins Herz
setzen, was oft gemacht wird.
So haben wir
Kopf und Herz verbunden.
Wir sind mit ihnen schon mal
in der gleichen Richtung unterwegs.
Ich hatte an einem Tag
eine Mathe-, eine Deutsch-
und eine Englischprüfung.
Ich hatte keine Lust, zu lernen.
Nachdem ich
dieses Armband angeschaut
und mein Motto abgerufen habe,
begann ich zu lernen.
Als ich die Prüfung
zurückbekommen habe,
war ich in Mathe
mit einer 5,5 Klassenbeste.
Wow!
Dazu eine 6 ist Deutsch
und eine 5,5 in Englisch.
Wie heisst dein tolles Motto,
das zu solchen Höhenflügen
geführt hat?
"Mit Mut und voller Energie
erreiche ich mächtig mein Ziel
und zaubere ein Lächeln
in die Herzen der Menschen."
Das hast du jetzt gerade erreicht.
Ein Bild für Matthias.
Das sollte
die Milchstrasse darstellen.
Das ist der Weg, dein Weg.
Hier beginnst du,
das sind deine Erfolge,
gekennzeichnet mit diesen Sternen.
Und das sind die Sterne,
die du noch erreichen kannst.
Die in dir stecken.
Und wenn du Erfolg hast,
zeichnest du weitere Sterne.
So kommst du zu deinem Ziel.
Matthias.
So schön.
Kannst du uns
dein Motto nochmals nennen? - Ja.
"So gross wie die Milchstrasse
verfolge ich geduldig meinen Weg
und erkenne meine Möglichkeiten."
Schön.
Hast du Angst vor der Prüfung?
Also nur ein bisschen,
könnte man sagen.
Nur ein bisschen?
- Ja.
Angst wovor?
Dass ich es nicht schaffe.
Das ist meine einzige
und grösste Angst.
Sprichst du mit jemandem über
deine Angst, es nicht zu schaffen?
Nein.
Denkst du, du schaffst die Prüfung?
Oder was sagen die Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer? Was ist dein Gefühl?
Wenn ich so weitermache,
dann schaffe ich es.
* Orientalische Klänge *
Man ist und man bleibt immer,
schon wenn man den Nachnamen
irgendwo angeben muss,
einer von denen
und nicht einer von uns.
Man vernimmt das auch
von ChagALL-Schülern,
wenn sie sich
für Lehrstellen bewerben,
von jenen mit schwierig
auszusprechenden Namen,
ungewöhnlichen Namen,
dass eine gewisse latente
Fremdenfeindlichkeit da ist.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja so,
dass sich unsere Gesellschaft,
wenn sie das Potenzial
dieser Jugendlichen nicht fördert,
etwas entgehen lässt.
Dann lassen wir das brachliegen.
Das können wir uns nicht leisten.
Wir brauchen doch
alle jungen Menschen
mit dem grösstmöglichen Beitrag
an die Gesellschaft,
den sie leisten können.
Was wir immer wieder hören und
was uns natürlich auch freut, ist,
dass es Jugendliche gibt,
die nur jemanden brauchen,
der an sie glaubt
und der ihnen zutraut,
dass sie ihr ganzes Potenzial
abrufen können -
und schon schaffen sie es.
Grüezi
- Grüezi.
Ich nehme Falafel.
Schau, was ist das? Lammgrill-Box?
Das ist Lammfleisch.
- Lammfleisch in einer Box.
Guten Appetit.
- Merci.
Essen!
Jetzt sind wir ja alle da.
Wie weit ist Ausgrenzung
für Roshani ein Thema?
Ich sehe und höre solche Dinge
auch heute immer noch.
Ich sehe solche Dinge
auch bei fremden Leuten,
die ich gar nicht kenne.
Es wird oft verallgemeinert.
Ich bin nicht mehr verletzt,
denn ich lasse es nicht mehr
an mich herankommen.
Das bringt nichts,
das kostet nur Energie.
Es ist etwas, das einfach existiert.
Roshani, hallo!
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut. Und dir?
Auch gut.
Roshani trifft Anina,
ihre Freundin aus der Gymnasiumszeit.
Mit ihr pflegt sie auch
nach dem Abschluss der Schule
einen engen Kontakt.
Wie sieht es mit Genf aus?
Gibt es schon was Neues?
Ja, ich bin am Planen.
Ich suche eine Wohnung.
Ich bin an der Uni Genf
eingeschrieben.
Du hast dich schon angemeldet?
- Ja.
Wirklich? Toll.
- Eingeschrieben für Humanmedizin.
Wie läuft es bei dir im Praktikum?
Ich habe jetzt Urlaub,
noch ein paar Tage.
Aber es ist toll.
Es ist halt auch wieder Schule.
Mit Kindern zusammenarbeiten?
- Ja.
Es ist eine schwierige Frage,
wo ich verwurzelt bin.
Ich fühle mich aber
mehr als Schweizerin,
weil ich hier geboren
und aufgewachsen bin.
Sagen wir es so:
Ich würde nie von hier wegziehen.
Es ist definitiv meine Heimat,
um zu wohnen.
Ich geniesse es aber auch sehr,
ab und zu meine Heimat zu besuchen
und dort meine Zeit zu geniessen.
Aber ich bin
definitiv hier beheimatet.
Guten Tag miteinander.
Wir haben die letzte Woche
vor der grossen Prüfung.
Ich habe für euch
eine Lernkontrolle vorbereitet.
Ich werde euch nicht überprüfen.
Ihr könnt feststellen, wo ihr steht,
ob ihr noch Lücken habt.
Mohamed, wie geht es dir
so kurz vor den Prüfungen?
Ich bin aufgeregt.
Hast du das Gefühl, du musst noch
etwas repetieren im Fach Deutsch?
Ja, die Satzglieder.
- Die Satzglieder also.
Konntest du deine Deutschnote
im letzten Semester verbessern?
Sie ist gleich geblieben.
Wer von euch konnte denn die
Zeugnisnote in Deutsch verbessern?
Inwiefern hast du dich verbessert?
Ich habe mich von einer 4,5
auf eine 5 verbessert.
Sehr gut. Das freut mich.
Wie geht es dir? Nach deiner
Prüfung, vor deiner Prüfung?
Das wollen Sie nicht wissen.
Du bist sehr nervös, nicht?
- Ja.
Gut. Dann machen wir doch jetzt
zusammen diese Lernkontrolle.
Kannst du alle Zeitformen aufzählen?
Präsens, Präteritum,
Perfekt, Plusquamperfekt,
Futur 1, Futur 2.
Sehr gut. Danke schön.
Könnt ihr mir sagen, welche Wortart
nicht veränderbar ist?
Partikel.
- Ganz richtig.
Welches schliessen wir zuerst aus,
welche Partikelsorte? Melvin.
Ich glaube,
Präpositionen und Konjunktionen.
Zuerst Präpositionen.
Was ist Deklination?
Mohamed.
- Veränderbar.
Aber sie ist ja etwas anders
veränderbar als die Konjugation.
Wie verändern wir die Pronomen?
Man setzt sie in einen Fall.
Kennst du noch
den lateinischen Begriff?
Kasus.
- Kasus.
Welche zwei anderen Wortarten
sind auch noch deklinierbar?
Ajitha?
- Das Verb.
Nein.
- Das Adjektiv.
Adjektive.
Ihr habt das
auf Anhieb richtig gemacht.
D.h., ihr habt jetzt
diese Wortarten wirklich intus.
Erinnert ihr euch noch,
wie ihr zu Beginn von ChagALL
mit der Deklination
gar nicht klargekommen seid?
Und jetzt kennt ihr alle Unterarten.
Jemand von euch hat vorhin
alle Pronomen aufgezählt.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das sitzt jetzt, oder?
Gut. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Mohamed
auf dem Weg zur Aufnahmeprüfung
für die Kantonsschule Zürich Nord.
Für ihn ist es ein wichtiger Tag.
Sein Ziel hat er klar vor Augen:
Er will an die ETH.
An die Prüfung
geht er mit einem guten Gefühl.
Die Nervosität
habe er im Griff, sagt er.
Ob Mohamed
die Prüfung geschafft hat,
wird er in rund zwei Wochen erfahren.
Die Chancengleichheit
der Kinder von Zugewanderten
ist Jürg Schoch ein Anliegen.
Chancengleichheit ist dann gegeben,
wenn jedes Kind seine Wünsche gemäss
seinem Potenzial umsetzen kann.
Die Kinder
sind sehr unterschiedlich begabt.
sind auch sehr verschiedenartig,
auch von der Motivation her.
Aber Chancengerechtigkeit
würde heissen:
Ich bekomme die Chance,
das aus mir zu machen,
was in mir steckt,
wenn ich es will.
Die Schülerinnen und Schüler
haben in verschiedenen Gymnasien
des Kantons Zürich
die Aufnahmeprüfung abgelegt.
Einige von ihnen
auch am Gymnasium Unterstrass.
Stefan Marcec teilt ihnen
die Resultate persönlich mit.
Und wie geht's dir so?
- Gut.
Ich glaube, es wird dir gleich
besser gehen: Du hast bestanden.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, super!
Wirklich?
- Ja. Und zwar sehr gut bestanden.
Hast du das nicht erwartet?
- Nein.
Sicher nicht?
- Gar nicht.
Wie lange bist du in der Schweiz?
- Vier Jahre.
Das ist wahnsinnig!
Von 61 Schülerinnen und Schülern
bist du auf Rang 22.
Auch die Zwillinge
Franciska und Viktoria
warten gespannt auf den Bescheid.
Wie geht es dir jetzt?
- Ich bin sehr nervös.
Ich erlöse dich:
Du hast es geschafft.
Gratuliere!
- Oh mein Gott!
Sicher?
- Ja.
So, jetzt darfst du
schreien, tanzen und singen.
Ich kann es gar nicht glauben.
- Wieso nicht?
Ich glaube es schon,
aber irgendwie ...
Ich war nicht überrascht.
Und du warst ziemlich gut.
Schauen wir nach deiner Schwester.
- Ja.
Freust du dich für deine Schwester?
- Ja, sehr.
Willst du dich noch mehr freuen?
Du hast bestanden.
Oh mein Gott!
Schön.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Du darfst weinen, schreien ...
Der Druck war wohl doppelt so gross,
nachdem es die Schwester
geschafft hatte.
Gut, schön. Willkommen!
* Kreischen *
Das ist auch das Schöne am Beruf.
Ich habe es dir gesagt: "Wenn es
eine schafft, dann die andere auch."
Nochmals herzliche Gratulation.
- Tschüss!
Ich gratuliere nochmals.
Sie werden im Programm ChagALL+
noch durch die Probezeit
des Gymnasiums begleitet.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Matthias, hast du Bescheid erhalten?
- Ja.
Wie ist das Ergebnis?
- Schlecht. Nicht bestanden.
Bist du enttäuscht?
Hm?
- Bist du enttäuscht?
Ja, schon ein bisschen.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Ich suche schon
nach dem nächsten Weg.
Ich werde jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich
das zehnte Schuljahr machen.
Ich werde eine Lehrstelle suchen
und mich auf die Prüfung der
Informatikmittelschule vorbereiten.
Ich habe die Prüfung bestanden.
Das habe ich am Freitag
im Internet erfahren.
Ich war sehr nervös.
Ich war überrascht,
dass ich bestanden habe.
Mit einer 4,05.
Ich war total erleichtert.
Mit ist ein Stein
vom Herzen gefallen.
Wie hat deine Familie reagiert?
Meine Mutter telefonierte
gerade mit ihrer Cousine.
Sie hörte,
dass ich "bestanden" gerufen habe.
Und dann ...
Mein Vater benachrichtigte dann
per WhatsApp meine Familie
in Deutschland,
Italien und Frankreich.
Sie wurden
für ihre Anstrengungen belohnt -
teils mit wirklich nochmals
deutlich besseren Zeugnisnoten.
Manche haben zu Hause
in den Spitzenzeiten.
bis zu 10 Std. zusätzlich
Hausaufgaben gelöst.
Aber bestimmt immer 2-4 Std.
haben sie jede Woche zu Hause
für ChagAll gearbeitet.
Ich finde das
eine sehr beträchtliche Anstrengung.
Viktoria schaffte den Sprung ans
Gymnasium, Ajitha gelang es nicht.
Sie beginnt nun eine Berufslehre
als Dentalassistentin.
Herzliche Gratulation.
Von 26 Schülerinnen und Schülern
haben 16 ihr Ziel erreicht.
Die Mehrheit geht an ein Gymnasium,
andere haben eine Lehrstelle gefunden
und setzen ihre Ausbildung
in einer Berufs-
oder Fachmaturitätsschule fort.
Für uns ist das eine
der schönsten, anspruchsvollsten
und befriedigendsten Arbeiten,
die wir haben,
junge Menschen,
die sich bilden wollen,
die danach lechzen, etwas zu lernen,
dabei zu unterstützen,
diesen Weg zu gehen.
Wenn sie dann Erfolg haben,
ist das enorm befriedigend.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Philipp Schlatter - 2017